do one two three four five one two one
two might check from the
stick mic at the chair position one two
three four five one two one two
one two three four five one two one two
one two three four five one two one two
two three four five one two one two
you wanna do this small come back here
check one two testing one two check one
two testing one
two one two three four five robo cam
robo cam should be on show
it should be on channel two not one
not one channel two one two three
four five channel one should be podium
i'm still talking
channel one should be on podium channel
two should be this microphone one
two three four five nbc my check
unilateral one two three four five
channel two channel two one two one two
not one channel two test one two test
one two
check check check my check one two
one two one two
test one two check one two test one two
check one two
go to the cuts camera and go on the
podium
check one two one two three four five my
check
check one two portion my check check one
two you got me here so joe
has it head-on has it
on channel one check one two one two
three four five
all right
all right this should be your channel
two channel two wireless
one two do you want to turn it off at
this point
check one two one two one two three four
five we still have
about five
five
got it yep what happened
oh
thank you uh
so
okay
for us
two one two
you got
really
um hey does uh she need an isb does she
have to do
that right in the chair
yeah oh
welcome back
[Music]
okay
yes
there we go
good night
uh
oh oh
yes
i know
all right
we got this
um
for what
i like it
um
i usually
so
right
i
oh
come on
one
that's good
oh
here
hey
uh
okay
first
yes
yes
nice
it's
yeah no no jaden
oh you're right you're right you ready
okay
hey
um
train station
hmm
is
so
yes
uh uh
so
hmm
you know the world's watching the tests
foreign
okay
hey
all right
yes
i thought
okay
so
so
so
two-minute warning thank you
you
oh
so
good afternoon everyone happy friday
uh today we are joined by national
economic council director brian diese
who will highlight some key aspects of
the executive orders the president is
issuing today related to the economy
and underline the their impact on
american families and workers
brian is kind enough to take a few
questions i didn't have to twist his arm
too much
but he does have to go to a briefing
with the president so i'll be the bad
cop and come up when he has to
uh cut it off go ahead brian
thanks jen
um so i wanted to just take a couple
minutes to talk to you about the
uh executive actions that the the
president will take today
um but you start with a little bit of
context
our economy is at a very precarious
moment
we are 10 million jobs short still of
where
the economy was when this pandemic
started
last month the economy lost jobs for the
first time since last spring
retail sales fell last month and just
yesterday we saw another
900 000 americans file for unemployment
insurance
that's a weekly rate that is higher than
any week during the great recession
it's a moment that requires decisive
action
to beat this pandemic
and support the economic recovery that
american families need
that's why a week ago president biden
laid out a comprehensive
american rescue plan a plan
that is focused on changing the course
of the pandemic getting students back in
school
and giving families and businesses a
bridge to the economic recovery
while also addressing the stark
inequities in our economy that this
crisis has exposed
we have been engaging closely with
members of congress with governors
mayors business and labor organizations
in the weeks since and
will continue to do so and hope that
congress will move quickly
to consider this important proposal
without delay uh at the same time the
american people are hurting
uh and they can't afford to wait uh they
need help
right now um and that's uh the
motivation behind the actions that the
president will take today
i want to be very clear these actions
are not a substitute
for comprehensive legislative relief
but they will provide a critical
lifeline to millions of families
[Music]
so uh just to get into the specifics the
president will sign two executive orders
today
uh the first directs agencies to
consider a number of actions
that will provide emergent emergency
relief for working families
affected by the kobe 19 crisis
within existing authorities and helping
to correct some of the
errors omissions of the prior
administration in providing families
with relief
i just want to touch on a couple
elements that are in that executive
order to give you a sense of what we're
talking about
on the issue of food insecurity which is
a growing
crisis in america of hunger nearly 30
million americans last week said that
they didn't have enough
food to put on the table
so the president will ask the department
of agriculture to consider taking
immediate steps to provide nutrition
assistance to hard-hit families
first by increasing pandemic ebt
benefits by about 15
this is the the program that is aimed at
supporting uh families who traditionally
rely on the school lunch program to
provide
meals to millions of kids through their
schools
so in the pandemic the pandemic evt
program
provides direct assistance to families
to cover those costs
but the way it is being implemented
today doesn't get uh
to the full costs necessary so
with these changes in eligible family
with three children would get about
an additional hundred bucks over two
months to help pay for food
uh second uh increasing the snap
benefits emergency snap benefits for as
many as 12 million low-income americans
this is the core uh program uh targeted
at preventing hunger in america
and these changes again for a family of
four would mean about a fifteen to
twenty percent benefit increase
uh and third uh revising the thrifty
food plan which is really the basis for
determining snap benefits
um is out of date and needs to be
updated to better
reflect the cost of a healthy diet
another element of this executive order
is to promote worker safety
and here president biden will ask the
department of labor to consider
clarifying that
workers have a federally guaranteed
right to refuse employment
that would jeopardize their health and
if they do so they will still qualify
five for unemployment insurance this is
a
a common sense step to make sure that
workers have a right to safe work
environments
and that we don't put workers in the
middle of a pandemic
in a position where they have to choose
between their own livelihoods
and the health of they and their
families
the second executive order that the the
the president will sign
uh is focused on the jobs of federal
workers
and on federal contractors he will
direct his administration to initiate a
process
starting today that would allow him
within 100 days to issue an executive
order requiring federal contractors to
pay
at least a 15 minimum wage and provide
emergency
paid leave to workers this was something
that the president
talked about on the campaign that when
we're using taxpayer dollars
federal contractors should provide the
benefits and pay that workers deserve
uh the order will also protect and
empower federal employees
uh who've dedicated their careers to
serving the american people
uh many in very difficult circumstances
during this pandemic
um and the steps will include restoring
collective bargaining power and worker
protections for federal workers
um eliminating schedule f so-called
schedule f which has
threatened the uh protections of career
employees
and also provided a potential pathway to
borrow political employ
appointees into civil service
and also promoting a 15 minimum wage uh
by directing uh the
opm the office of public management
management to develop recommendations to
pay
more federal workers at least 15 an hour
uh finally just one final note in
addition to the executive orders that
we'll be issuing today
um we will be focusing on another key
priority of the president and the vice
president which is equitable reef
relief to small businesses
in previous rounds of relief too much of
the support
that has been dedicated to small
businesses
has left out the smallest businesses
mom and pop businesses that don't have
existing connections with a financial
institution and in particular black
latino asian and
native american owned businesses were
shut out completely
and a lot of that is because the
outreach and communication from the
federal government was either unclear or
just non-existent
and so uh too many of those companies
have
been denied relief and many of them have
had to shut their doors for good
uh the president is completely focused
on uh on changing that
and he has uh he has directed us to take
immediate steps to make sure that we're
listening to these communities
uh we're taking their advice on how to
improve the distribution of relief
um so just this morning i met along with
representatives of the small business
administration with
dozens of groups representing black and
brown owned businesses
and other underserved communities as
well as lenders to hear their ideas
on how we can improve communications uh
and act on them
we discussed the president's idea of
having navigators
who are dedicated to helping small
business owners find
the right relief programs fill out
paperwork get the money into their bank
accounts
the kind of support that many of these
businesses don't have because of
embedded relationships that more
well-connected businesses do
there are some groups out there in the
country who are doing this really
successfully
we're determined to learn from them and
to scale those efforts
uh nationwide and in in this vein i look
forward i will be joining uh the
vice president harris later today she
will be meeting with small business
owners to discuss both the american
rescue plan
and the need for more effective small
business relief
delivered without delay so
uh that's uh that is uh that is today
that is our focus through a set of
executive orders and i'm happy to take
a couple questions of which you all have
many
uh sure sure um this is the good cop
back out there
thank you for taking questions today um
i want to ask you about
the call on sunday with a bipartisan
group of lawmakers what can you tell us
about the call will president biden be
on the call and what is your message
to moderate republicans like mitt romney
who say
the economy can't have another stimulus
after you just passed a 900 billion
dollar relief package last month
yeah thanks kristen so so uh the the
president has made clear to uh his team
that we should be reaching out
to members of congress from both parties
uh to make the case for the rescue plan
and to engage with them understand
uh uh their concerns so that's what
we're uh we're doing
with myself and uh senior members of the
team
uh we have been doing that over the
course of time we'll continue to do that
including uh the the call on sunday that
uh that i'll be doing with
uh a um uh uh a group of uh senators uh
and we'll continue that engagement
uh going forward uh in terms of the in
terms of the of the
uh the message uh it's it's pretty clear
uh we're at a precarious moment for the
virus and the economy
without decisive action we risk
falling into a very serious economic
hole
even more serious than the crisis we
find ourselves in
and and economists across the board
um including today uh president trump's
uh
uh former chairman of the council of
economic advisers uh arguing strenuously
that now is the time
for that type of decisive action for the
economy
and that we can't wait to provide the
resources
to make sure that we can open schools we
can get vaccine
shots in people's arms and we can
provide that bridging relief
to families and small businesses there's
a lot of support
i i met with a group of mayors yesterday
a
bipartisan group of mayors from the cops
across the country you hear from mayors
you hear from governors
just crying out that in order to take on
these crises the public health
and the pandemic and the economic crisis
at the same time
now is the moment for that kind of
decisive action that's the case we'll be
making
just to be clear brian will president
biden be on the call and if not why not
if this is still urgent
so like i said uh we're doing all
outreach
the president has directed the team to
do outreach to uh members of congress
to business and labor organizations to
uh
um to mayors and governors and we're in
the process of doing that
um i'll be having that conversation on
sunday you can expect that other members
of the administration will be engaging
uh with members of congress uh uh across
time as well
if i could what would a february
impeachment trial
how would a february impeachment trial
impact getting the covet relief package
passed
look i think that uh we have faced
we are facing right now a period of
multiple crises
and what we're going to need is to be
able to act um
on multiple fronts and so that's uh
certainly um we understand and has
jen has spoken to we understand that uh
the senate has a constitutional
obligation uh in this context uh
but we also have these pressing economic
and pandemic priorities as well so we're
gonna that's that's why we're engaging
uh that's why we're focused on
uh making the case um and certainly with
the expectation that congress will
uh will heed that call and move forward
i promise to do a whole briefing after
this so just we'll do the econ questions
for brian
go ahead thank you very much if you are
able to pass this nearly two trillion
dollar plan
do you envision this being the last
round of stimulus or do you think you
may
need to do more what i can tell you is
if we don't act
now we will be in a much worse place
and we will find ourselves needing to do
much more to dig out of a much deeper
hole
the so so what i can tell you is the
single most important thing economically
right now
is to take decisive action uh
along the lines of what we've laid out
uh in this rescue plan
uh and you hear again from economists
across the board whether it's the
federal reserve
uh the international monetary fund and
economic experts across the political
spectrum as well
when you're at a moment that is as
precarious as the one we
find ourselves in the risk of doing too
little the risk of undershooting
far outweighs the risk of doing too much
and that's the economic logic the
economic case behind
this package i think you've also heard
the president
clearly um explain that his economic
approach uh
is one where rescue and recovery need to
come together
and he'll be speaking more about his uh
recovery plans uh
in the coming weeks that are about
building back better
an urgent priority to start creating the
kinds of good jobs that we know we're
going to need coming out of this crisis
after the recession it took nearly a
decade to get the country back to full
employment under the obama
administration
if you're able to pass this rescue
package how long
do you think it will take for every
american who wants a job
to be able to have one well i i would
just point to you know
uh just one example of a of an
independent analysis that was done
of the american rescue plan by uh
moody's and what they
said uh what they found was that if we
passed the american rescue plan now
we could see seven and a half million
jobs created just this year
and we could see a return to full
employment a full year
ahead of what is projected if we don't
so those are the stakes uh
involved uh and without this kind of
decisive action
uh we're going to have a much deeper
economic hole uh and that's
uh that that's why we are so focused on
making the case for
a decisive action now thanks
john and brian um i wanted to follow in
walker's question a little bit
the president's talked about seeking
unity on on this bill but also being
clear-eyed when there's policy
differences so i'm wondering if
after this call which is with sort of
the bipartisan
coalition that you'd need to get this
bill passed if you expect to know
whether the white house will
pursue legislation in bipartisan
legislation
or sort of head towards a
legislation through reconciliation and
i'm also wondering if you could talk
about
what sort of red lines will be the point
at which you say okay
if you're not willing to negotiate about
this in the bill
we're gonna just start working with
democrats as speaker pelosi and others
have been very cheap to do
yeah well i guess i'd say two things to
that
the first is if you look at the elements
of the american rescue plan
it was designed with a bottom-up focus
on what our
experts saying is the actual need what's
the actual need to get
schools open what's the actual need to
have a national vaccination distribution
plan
to underwrite the strategy that you
heard dr fauci
and the president talk about yesterday
and what's the need to
support families and businesses during
this transition
and the second thing the second thing is
that as a result of that i think we're
seeing
a lot of support as i said bipartisan
mayors bipartisan governors business
organizations
chamber of commerce business roundtable
economists across the board
saying this is a this is a an
appropriate response
to an unprecedented economic uh uh
circumstance
uh so that's the um that's the approach
that we
are taking and that's the um that's the
perspective
that we are uh bringing here and i think
that uh
we are heartened to see that kind of
support
and that's the conversation that we're
gonna have with members of congress be
they
republicans or democrats including you
know looking at where we are
where we've come over the last year and
the lessons we've learned that
without decisive action uh we know uh um
uh the the consequences and so now is a
moment not to
uh undershoot or to wait and see now
it's a moment to act
i guess my question is i think a lesson
that a lot of
the president obama and others have
talked about from the aca fight was
continuing to court republican support
beyond uh
a point of it being productive and so
i'm wondering for you guys
what is the decision point going to be
where you
you know you might have republican
mayors but it doesn't look like you have
republican senators right now
at what point do you say this is is no
longer worth kind of pushing forward
we're we are we're making the case uh we
are engaging uh we're having
conversations we're listening
uh and we are also focused on the
urgency uh and the need to act and so
you know what i can tell you is um
that's where uh the president's focus is
that's where the vice president's focus
is that'll be continued to be our focus
is
uh we want to um we we want to engage uh
and we want to act
and that's going to be what guides us
here but brian we'll come back
um thank you for doing this brian um
back to the
point of the objections of some of these
republican senators who have already
spoken out
they say they just passed 900 million or
so at the end of the year
most of it isn't even out yet how do you
know if that money hasn't gotten into
the system yet
that you even need to release more at
this point
why why move ahead with a trillion
dollar plan of the 900 million that's
already been approved hasn't even gone
up
sure well first of all you know uh we
waited
for six months or or uh or more before
uh congress acted and so really a lot of
what that 900 billion was doing
was filling a hole in the second half of
2020
that desperately needed to be filled uh
and so uh
so it's this is not this is not an issue
of
of of of congress acting uh too much
it's of an issue of not acting
uh uh enough um and the second is if you
look at the components of the 900
billion dollars
again we could go line by line uh but
these are
resources that are either already out
the door
or already or are addressing economic
challenges or public health challenges
that were in the rear view mirror so as
we find ourselves today
looking forward we need a very set
very decisive set of actions if we are
actually going to
get schools open if we're actually going
to get a vaccination program
uh uh up and running and i think that
the case that we will make is
is that today uh we're not where we need
to be
uh and if we go line by line in the
american rescue plan
these provisions are have been designed
based on
an assessment of need um and we think
they're actually
going to absolutely be necessary so you
know i think that um
looking forward um we're quite confident
that this is
this is this is the prudent assessment
of needs i want to clarify two quick
things
um how many federal employees or federal
contractors
are making minimum wage right now
do you guys know so i don't i don't have
an i don't have an estimate of that
right now
and then last night you said that there
are roughly
eight million people who haven't
received their stimulus checks yes
how do you find them so uh it's it's a
great question
this is principally an issue associated
with people who are non-filers so
they're not filing
income taxes in most cases because they
don't make enough money
to need to file federal income taxes and
so as a result
the way that the irs and the treasury
department uh in the previous
administration has focused on getting
those checks out has been to to work
through the uh the tax system
but those are people who uh who are
legally entitled to those checks
uh and uh so we have a number of
strategies that we're going to pursue
um and that the today we'll start with
the president's executive order
uh to direct the department of treasury
to consider a whole range of efforts
including creating an online portal
uh that would allow people to easily
identify if they're eligible
to work through counterpart
organizations to
actually affirmatively do outreach to
communities where we know there are
significant numbers of these of these
families and these individuals
to let people know that they may be
available some of this is
uh education outreach as well um and i
would just con
you know it's it's a little connected to
what i was saying about small business
as well
what the president is directing all of
us to do is to really focus on
the affirmative steps that we can take
um an affirmative strategy to say
it's not enough to just say well if if
uh
if folks don't know or if they don't
have a network then
then they're left out in the cold we're
going to we're going to work both
directly
in what the federal government can do
and with partner organizations to try to
make sure that every american who's
entitled to a benefit is actually
receiving it there's someone out there
right now who hears you saying this
realizes i'm eligible and i haven't
gotten it right now today
is there a way for them to raise their
hand and say something might check
well starting today we're going to start
a process
um to uh to make that a lot easier
a lot easier for families including uh
being able to go online and do that but
that's that's work that's going to start
today
thank you um i just had one small
question on the mechanics of the
eo uh targeting the food insecure
does the usda have the money to
distribute these plus ups that you're
talking about
or is there going to need to be an
appropriations from congress so these
are mandatory appropriated programs so
there
there's no need for additional
congressional action um it's a change in
regulation
on the eligibility for benefits um so
so these are these are changes that can
be made under existing statute and under
existing budgetary uh authority without
any
additional action from congress there
though too yeah it's a
mandatory program so it it operates
based on uh
um the the benefits are paid out based
on
uh who is eligible great thank you brian
i'll do that great thank you all
all right everyone happy friday i have a
couple of things
just at the top some things you've been
asking about so hopefully they address
some of the questions you may have
first we applaud the senate's strong
bipartisan confirmation of lloyd austin
who has been breaking barriers all of
his life as the first black
secretary of defense in our nation's
history secretary austin's confirmation
is a major benefit to our national
security
and he's going to hit the ground running
leading the pentagon
he will be sworn in uh today but he will
be uh
he will be sworn in more officially by
the not more officially i should say but
he will be sworn in more ceremoniously
on monday by the vice president
similarly the president is very happy to
see that janet yellen
the first woman who would ever lead the
u.s treasury department was unanimously
voted out of committee this morning
this should only be the beginning we're
facing unprecedented challenges and
threats to our national security
during these emergencies in our country
urgently needs our secretary of homeland
security in place alejandro mayorkas is
one of the most knowledgeable homeland
security experts in the country
he's earned bipartisan praise and he's
been previously confirmed
by the senate three times this is a
confirmation that we are going to
continue to press on
in all of our engagements and
conversations with the senate
i also have some news to share on the
president's response to domestic
violence extremism
the january 6th assault on the capital
and the tragic deaths
and destruction that occurred
underscored
what we have long known the rise of
domestic violent extremism is a serious
and growing national security threat
the biden administration will confront
this threat with the necessary resources
and resolve
we are committed to developing policies
and strategies based on facts on
objective and rigorous analysis
and on our respect for protected free
speech and political activities
our initial work on dve will broadly
fall into three areas
the first is a tasking from president
biden sent to the odni today
requesting a comprehensive threat
assessment coordinated with the fbi
and dhs on domestic violent extremism
this assessment will draw on the
analysis from across the government
and as appropriate non-governmental
organizations
the key point here is that we want
fact-based analysis
upon which we can shape policy though so
this is really the first step in the
process
and we will rely on our appropriate law
enforcement and intelligence officials
to provide that analysis
the second will be the building of an
nsc capability
to focus on countering domestic violent
extremism
as a part of this the nsc will undertake
a policy review effort
to determine how the government can
share information better about this
threat
support efforts to prevent
radicalization disrupt violent extremist
networks and more
there's important work already underway
across the inter-agency encounter in
countering dve and we need to understand
better its current extent
and where there may be gaps to to
address
so we can determine the best path
forward the third will be coordinating
relevant parts of the federal government
to enhance and accelerate
efforts to address dve this considered
nsc convened
process will focus on addressing
evolving threats radicalization
the role of social media opportunities
to improve information sharing
operational responses and more
just a couple more items as you all know
right now the president and vice
president are having lunch
this is something they look forward to
doing every week they'll be discussing
their agenda particularly getting relief
to working families and containing
the covid crisis and i'm sure they'll
talk about the last
48 hours as well later today the
president will speak with prime minister
of canada justin trudeau we confirmed
that earlier this week he'll also speak
with
president of mexico andre manuel lopez
obrador
we'll have readouts of both of those
calls when they happen
yesterday evening the first lady held a
virtual event to honor and show
gratitude for the hard work of educators
across the country especially during
this difficult time of kovid
19 she was accompanied by the presidents
of both the american federation of
teachers and national education
association
over 11 000 educators attended the
virtual meeting
today she will tour the whitman walker
clinic uh in washington dc to highlight
and promote support services for cancer
patients and caregivers and while i know
that was in our
guidance we want to use this platform
here to also
share with you information about both
the vice president and the first lady
moving forward um one more item as well
um earlier this morning or late this
morning i should say
the president called general daniel
hoganson
uh who is the head of the national guard
um to
thank him for not just his work of the
last few weeks but the work of the
national guard
over the last several years uh he talked
about his own
personal commitment and connection to
the national guard
given his son had served previously and
he offered assistance
any assistance needed of both the
government but also on a personal level
and asked him to
reach out if there was anything uh that
he ever
needed uh i will stop there just a few
updates so i'm gonna
kick us off thank you um i know this has
been uh asked of you
uh several times but now that uh there
is a impeachment trial imminent does
president biden have a uh
opinion on whether uh former president
trump
should be convicted and then secondly
um with how this is going you're now
getting a little bit of momentum on
confirmations
you have all that you need to get going
on coronavirus
on the economy and so forth is this just
going to slow everything down
and does it also take away from the
ability to unify
well first remarkably at this moment in
history we have
some recent precedent of the senate
conducting
an impeachment trial while also doing
the business of the american people and
when the trial was being conducted last
january
it there were also hearings that were
happening nearly on a daily basis and we
expect that type of work to continue
i'll also note purely on an operational
level the house can also proceed
and continue to do the work on the
american rescue plan
uh move that uh forward and we certainly
expect and hope that they will do that
but what the president's view is what
cannot be delayed
uh through this process is his proposal
to get relief to the american people
at this time of crisis so he's confident
he remains confident after serving
decades in the senate that uh
the senate members of both parties can
walk and chew gum at the same time and
can move forward with the business of
the american people
does he believe that former president
trump should be convicted
well he's no longer in the senate and he
believes that it's up to the senate and
congress to determine uh how they will
hold the former president accountable
and what the mechanics and timeline of
that process will be
just a dvd if you don't mind are the
tools and methods available
to um federal law enforcement are they
what we need right now are we still
stuck in sort of a post-9 11
uh mine set and does there need to be
really broad radical uh rethinking about
how we sort of approach things in the
federal law enforcement
well uh the reason uh that the president
uh wanted to do this review and the
national security team wanted to do this
review is because
it's a priority to ensure we are
assessing what is happening in
government and how we can do it better
so clearly
more needs to be done that's why the
president is uh tasking
uh the national security team uh to do
exactly this review
on this his first his second full day in
office so it's sending
an indication of that let me just give
you just a little bit more information
homeland security advisor dr liz
sherwood randall has asked
joshua geltzer to pioneer scoping effort
in the first hundred days
in coordination with the senior director
for counter-terrorism claire
lincoln's gelter previously served as
the senior director for
counter-terrorism
on the national security council from
2015 through 2017
and deputy homeland security adviser
russ travers will also bring his
extensive experience so those are some
of the people who will be involved in
overseeing
this review and an assessment of what
the steps are going to be following
uh go ahead kristen thanks john um one
on impeachment and then if i could on
kobe
um on impeachment did house speaker
nancy pelosi
consult with president biden before
sending the article of impeachment
over to the senate i don't have any
calls between them to read out for you
kristin obviously they're in regular
touch i can say uh
from a previous question you asked brian
that he's been in touch with members of
both parties uh about
his agenda even since he was inaugurated
so obviously a range of topics come up
in those discussions but i don't have
anything more to read out for you on the
timing
leader mcconnell has said that he's
going to push for a february
timeline i know that you don't want to
comment specifically
on the timeline of this but how would a
february trial
impact the effort to get copenhagen
passed well the
president's expectation he believes in
the senate and their ability to
uh multitask and get the work and
business of the american people done
at the same time while they are
proceeding with an impeachment trial on
whatever timeline
it begins and ends on kristin so he's
coming
is mid-february fast enough he's going
to leave the timeline up to them but
what is important and again there's
precedent for this is that
they are continuing to move forward with
getting the relief to the american
people because that certainly can't wait
and be delayed until march april or may
we can't afford that
if i could follow up with you on what
you said about covet yesterday you said
your goal is a million shots per day
which would
double you said what the trump
administration was doing according to
the cdc
we have reached a million shots a day
last week
so given that given the urgent need for
vaccinations
why not getting higher well first of all
we're not packing up our bags
and and leaving uh on at 100 days
we felt it was important and we set that
goal before any american had received a
single shot
so the the incoming biden administration
felt it was important to set what was
described as a bold and ambitious goal
at the time and many doubted we could
even get there
so we want to set our own markers and
markers for the american public so that
they know we're meeting our goal
if we surpass that that's great we're
going to continue working after day 100
as well but there are a number of
factors here dr fauci also
talked about it's not just having the
access to the vaccine
right it's about addressing vaccine
hesitancy
it's about ensuring we have the
materials needed it's about
and you all have done reporting of
course on different issues going on in
states from new york and others where
there
are concerns about supply where there's
confusion about the process and we need
to address that
so there are a number of operational uh
challenges that are happening at the
same time
uh okay let's go ahead yeah uh following
up on
uh the vaccine stakeholders we've talked
to
state leaders medical experts have said
one of the questions
that they're trying to figure out is how
much vaccine is actually in the national
stockpile right now you have any sense
of that yet
our team as you know has been on the
ground for about 48 hours
but certainly what they want to
determine is
not just the operational issues i
reference but also what we're looking at
in terms of supply
we are as you may know we'll we are
going to
be starting uh briefings next week i
should say a couple times a week with
some of our health experts so
i expect they'll be able to provide some
update
of what they've reviewed and what they
have access to at that point in time
quick ones on the
previous occupant um house intelligence
committee chairman adam schiff is
calling on president biden not to extend
the courtesy
to president trump of getting access to
intelligence meetings is a decision been
made on that
uh not that i'm aware of but i'll follow
up with our national security team and
see we would certainly leave the
decision to them to the intelligence
community clear up the confusion here
about
these who exactly dismissed the chief
white house
pressure well it happened in an
administration or was it the previous
act
it is it is a very important question
i'm so happy you asked it uh it is
what happened before we walked in the
door and so i don't have any more
information than what we've provided
um go ahead not to belabor this point
but you've said that congress can walk
and chew gum at the same time which is
true but there are also so many hours
in the day has the president expressed
any concern that a senate trial will
slow down additional confirmations or
movement on a coping relief bill
only that it cannot uh there are only so
many hours in the day you're right
but again if there's a a senate trial
happening
uh in the senate of course it would
happen in the senate the house can move
forward on a package
and certainly there is capacity and
ability to have discussions have
hearings
take steps to move forward on the
president's coveted relief package
and we don't think it can be delayed or
it can wait so
they're going to have to find a path
forward he's confident they can do that
and president biden has made pretty
clear that he believes
former president trump is unfit to serve
does he think he should be barred from
holding federal office going forward
well we'll leave it to congress he ran
against him because he thought he was
unfit to serve and he's no longer
here because president biden beat him uh
but uh we'll leave the uh
steps uh the accountability steps to
congress to determine
there's two good covered questions any
update as to whether uh the president
may sit down with congressional leaders
to discuss and try and hammer out this
package
sure um well i i will say without giving
you specifics necessarily but um
which i know you're looking for so i
shouldn't have just locked myself into
that rabbit hole but um
but uh right but um the the president
has already
um done a number of calls with democrats
and republicans that will continue he's
very eager
to be uh closely involved uh roll up his
sleeves and be making calls himself
uh i don't soon but i don't have an
update on any meeting
i will though just add just for context
i know that what the reporting thanks to
your reporting i suppose
um about the meeting this weekend uh
kind of got out there and obviously
brian confirmed it
there are a lot of meetings happening at
one time with a lot of different
officials so i don't
i wouldn't see that as like this is the
negotiating tool that is one of many
engagements and one one of many
discussions that
the president the vice president uh
senior members of the white house team
are are having and are ongoing and as
outlined right now is he confident that
you have enough democrats on board with
this plan to pass this
well he announced the plan about a week
ago
right um and uh we are his view is that
this is how democracy should work which
is the president of the united states
announces um what his uh vision is
and what his plan his proposed plan is
to address the crises the american
people are facing
then there are ongoing discussions with
congress they like some pieces they
don't like other pieces
you all have seen democrats like many
pieces republicans even like some of the
pieces too
and we've he's had those encouraging
conversations but the final package
may not look exactly like the package
that he proposed that's okay that's how
the process the legislative process
should work
uh go ahead justin um thanks welcome
back um thank you
i had a question on kovid but i wanted
to start with just some housekeeping
from
questions you had earlier in the week
um uh on the plane we are certainly
aware of the
the um white house military units a
proposal that has been submitted to them
about reconsidering
the color scheme of air force one i can
confirm for you here
the president has not spent a moment
thinking about the color scheme of air
force one
or uh anything in the house or any
article
of anything so and no one is going to
submit a
decision memo to him on that particular
topic uh but
uh certainly we're aware of the proposal
and as there are any updates we're happy
to provide them to you
maybe a little more substantively i was
wondering you had
mentioned syringes yesterday but not if
you were
or not specific companies that might
have uh
had dpa contracts either started or come
in and then also
um dc statehood was an issue that was
raised in a previous briefing
sure um well on the first um i don't
have specific companies for you
i can circle back with our cova team and
see if we have more specifics obviously
those conversations are happening as we
speak
there was a question yesterday about
whether the defense production act had
been invoked it has been invoked so
those processes are now
rapidly ongoing the president has
supported dc statehood in the past um
that certainly remains his position
but uh i don't have anything for you on
the timeline or next steps there
oh so quickly a kind of trademark of the
last administration's
efforts were that there would be a big
announcement like jared kushner's
testing website and then
uh no timeline put on it and never
really materialized
so i was interested when the chief staff
last night said that there would be a
central clearinghouse for vaccine
information and i was wondering if you
could provide a sort of
expectation or timeline on what
americans could expect if there's a
dot gov email address of website or a
phone number that they could uh
go to to find out their specific uh
vaccination information
well i know all members of my family are
also asking the same question as i'm
sure yours are
it is something we're eager to do and
also provide more information to the
american public about
when they can call their pharmacy and
schedule an appointment just to make it
much easier
the lack of information and the lack
the disinformation at times about how
people can get the vaccine when they can
get the vaccine who's eligible has
created a great deal of confusion as you
all know
i don't have anything on the timeline
but i will remind you that the person
who saved healthcare.gov
and the uh the person who helped him are
working on the kova team so we're in
very good hands um
and they're certainly uh committed to
getting more information out in a more
accessible way
go ahead thanks man uh two questions the
first is uh having to do with the
operations of the west wing
curiosity about the community trump
administration
who has oval office walk-in privileges
in this white house do you have although
office walking privileges as you speak
for the president
and how is that access to the president
controlling you
well i i don't know that i'm going to
give you a list of everybody uh but i
will convey that
um you know since the first conversation
i had with then president-elect biden he
conveyed to me it was important that we
have regular conversations and
we're able to have a discussion about
how he sees things and
questions that are coming up to ensure
that we are providing you all with
information not just about our policies
which is of course pivotal but his
um also his thinking on issues so i
talked to him this morning
um and certainly um i expect and
anticipate i'll have a regular
conversations with him and there are a
number of other people
who uh who have those conversations with
him on a daily basis as well that's
that's part of his style and part of his
style of governing is to make sure
people
who are engaging with the outside world
uh have a have an understanding of his
thinking one more question for you is dr
debra burks still a member of this
president's covenant response team
i will have to circle back on that one
that's an excellent question i don't
have any information on it in front of
me
uh go ahead thank you ma'am um i've got
a question about the senate and
also a foreign policy question if you'll
let me great i love our
questions uh thank you senator mcconnell
and senator schumer have been going back
and forth
over discussions when it comes to a
power sharing situation
obviously the sticking point has been
the filibuster
are you concerned that those
negotiations could potentially delay
the president's legislative agenda his
nominees and then also
does the president still oppose
uh overturning the legislative
filibuster like he did in that interview
with the new york times
sure well his the president's position
uh hasn't changed uh but
uh i will say he's conveyed in
conversations with
uh both uh now leader schumer and
senator mcconnell that
uh they need to have their conversations
of course but he is eager to move
his uh rescue plan forward he's eager to
get relief to the american public he
wants to work with both of them to do
exactly that and he wants it to be a
bipartisan bill so that is his objective
his position hasn't changed he opposes
overturning legislative filibuster he
has spoken to this many times his
position has not changed
the previous administration on their way
out the door uh declared that china's
human rights abuses against uighur
muslims were quote crimes against
humanity
and quote a genocide does the president
agree
with that determination and will he keep
it
uh well i know that our secretary of
state is just about to get confirmed or
so
so senator mcconnell tells us and i'm
sure he will be reviewing i know he will
be reviewing
a number of the decisions and
assessments that have made obviously the
president
um has spoken before to the uh
to the horrific treatment of uyghurs but
i don't have anything more for you on it
i can
check with our national security team
and see if we have a more up-to-date
statement
go ahead hi just a couple of quick
follow-ups
the usda for families that
depend on schools to feed their children
that is
a hundred dollars for three children
every two months
i mean is that too little too late what
more are you thinking of doing
well first i will say that uh the
executive actions and this is something
when we were
discussing this with the president
earlier today are just part of his
effort to bring relief to the american
people he
his priority was overturning a number of
the detrimental steps that the
trump administration had taken and to
take steps that
he can through executive authority
through the review of the legal team
to do uh to to bring that relief but he
has also proposed
this a large package as many of you have
pointed out to all of us
to bring additional relief and he wants
to work with congress to
build on the executive actions to take a
bipartisan approach to making sure we
are
a kid that kids have food to eat that
people who don't have jobs have the
relief they need that we can get the
vaccine out that schools can reopen
uh those are all priorities of his but
the uh his big focus is
on doing that in a bipartisan way with
congress and that was that was this
other
detail mentioned about the 15 minimum
wage and i know
ryan spoke about federal contractors um
but the issues obviously faced a lot of
opposition in congress over the years
is president biden planning to speak to
senator schumer to bring the bill
the the the legislation that the house
passed on 15
to the senate i mean how does this
broadly help
workers around the country well
again this is this is just one part of
his step to provide relief
to the american people there are many
federal contractors of course serving
the government and
he felt it was something that was not
just right to do but something that was
necessary to do
but he has proposed a significant uh
relief package a package that will
provide assistance to many many
americans
and he will continue to advocate for the
15 minimum wage moving forward there's
no question about it go ahead
thank you very much jen and i'd like to
focus on vaccinations
there's arguably something that the
federal government can do in this front
um
in new york there is a looming trade
wreck that's actually happening today
governor cuomo and mayor de blasio say
that they're going to be running out of
their matches adverse doses of the
vaccine today they don't expect to get
more until tuesday so there's going to
be a three-day gap
is the federal government is president
biden going to do anything to prevent
that
well we've asked the cdc to look into
exactly this issue
and see what can be done i don't have
any update beyond that but certainly
we don't want any states to run out of
access to vaccine
we are hopeful that in the weeks ahead
as we uh get our sea legs here
and our team starts to operationalize
engagement with governors engagement
with local officials
uh to provide them a greater
understanding of
supply of what we are going to have
access to in a farther in a
time frame that's farther in advance
that we can avoid situations like this
in the future uh but we've asked the cdc
to look into what's happening
uh there's arguably a way that federal
government could just basically flip a
switch and
help alleviate some of this problem new
york city says it has
65 000 doses that are reserved for a
second shot
is the federal government considering
allowing those to be used for the first
shot so that there is not this three day
gap of
first shot vaccinations well as you know
in the past we have um
uh we have advocated for um releasing
additional access from the reserves but
we have
uh really deferred to health and medical
experts so
that's why we've asked the cdc to look
into what the options are
so you've asked the cdc to look into
this so there's well to look into to
have the conversation with
uh officials in new york and to look
into um
what is possible but i don't want to get
out of them we want to lean into health
and medical experts to make the
decisions
um go ahead thanks jen um one of the
executive orders that was signed
yesterday
requires that international travelers uh
quarantine or self-isolate is the is the
administration going to do anything to
enforce that rule or is it mostly an
honor system
and then on current matters one more has
the president considered establishing
any sort of national
memorial to memorialize those people who
died
from coronavirus sure um both are
excellent questions and the first one i
should have information on but
i'll have to follow up with you on both
of them i'm not aware of a discussion
about the second piece so
that's an interesting idea and i will
bring it back to people and see if
there's more to say
the immigration bill has the president
got a sense
of any feedback on the immigration bill
that was sent to the hill yesterday
um and is there an overall timeline for
when uh he'd like to see that
move well uh we already have co-sponsors
of the immigration bill as you may have
seen which is obviously a good sign
there are a number of experts as you
know because i'm guessing you have
covered this issue for some time if
you're asking with a level of detail uh
who have worked on immigration reform
had bipartisan discussions in the past
and we are hopeful that
this proposal that this bill that he
sent forward we sent forward yesterday
will be an opportunity for a reset to
really restart those discussions but we
expect that will be the first step here
and that we're hopeful that the
components of this
uh proposed bill which are different
from what has been proposed in the past
because it includes
smarter security it includes a path to
citizenship but it also includes funding
to address the root cause
will will help you the basis of those
discussions
and we would like to see them move
forward quickly
okay why don't you go ahead over here oh
you mentioned the issue of vaccine
hesitancy
does the president believe that all
americans should get the vaccine and
then for those who might be reluctant to
get it
how do you convince them that it's safe
well uh he does uh the more people who
are vaccinated the safer we are
and that uh health and medical experts
have also
conveyed that that's what i'm quoting uh
in terms of addressing vaccine hesitancy
it's
it's a big challenge you heard dr fauci
talk about this yesterday and
uh it may it will be easier for the
first tranche
of americans to get the to convince them
to get the vaccine they're just looking
for information on where to go and how
to sign up and
how to get grandma to come with them it
is really the next layer
of people who are concerned as you
alluded to about the safety
uh and about the efficacy um and
unfortunately there is a
um a large percent a larger than should
be percentage in
minority communities communities of
color um
and so we've been quite thoughtful or we
want to be quite thoughtful
about how we do outreach and engagement
obviously it's making it accessible so
ensuring we have these community centers
and health centers that can
can provide the vaccine but also who's
communicating
on behalf of the government or on behalf
of the
of the safety of the vaccine the
president certainly will be doing that
the vice president will be doing that
i know a lot of celebrities have offered
that's okay but what's been interesting
in the data are great
we welcome that but what's interesting
in the data is that local doctors
and local officials um you know people
from the community
are people who are mo often most trusted
and so we're really trying to empower
uh and and be able to fund local
communities to be able to to be the
spokespeople to
build that trust uh go ahead in the back
um thank you john um on the you
mentioned that the copen package the
talks may evolve
it may change the package and already
some things that you feel like there's
bipartisan support for
is there any consideration that's taken
place or that may take place
in separating some of these pieces out
and passing the things
first and foremost that may generate
bipartisan support given
the urgency that you've talked talked
about well um
you know i will say as brian said that
uh our objective here
the way that the package was designed
was to address
the core issues of the crisis so i think
the tricky piece of that question is
do you delay vaccine funding to
distribute the vaccine
do you delay funding for unemployment
insurance do you delay funding to reopen
schools
nobody wants to be having a conversation
about why schools aren't reopened in may
or june democrats republicans no members
of congress so
there are key components in here that um
we
uh that he in the package that was
designed to address the current crises
so right now we're having a discussion
about the big package but as you noted
uh there are viewpoints points of view
no surprise about many components of it
we certainly understand that and we
welcome the discussion and engagement
with members of both parties
timeline on the fact-finding period for
the domestic violent extremism
uh orders that you the letters that
you've sent is is there a period when
that you're expecting to get maybe
something
we're getting the report back uh i don't
believe
we have outlined that yet let me we can
follow up with you if there's a specific
timeline that we're putting out publicly
at this point go ahead janet yellen in
committee yesterday
said that president biden wouldn't be
signing any free trade deals because the
focus was on the domestic economy and
infrastructure where does that leave the
potential
for a uk u.s trade deal which
is it months away or next year or year
after
well i i can't give you any timeline i
will say that
uh what is important to the president
and also our national security advisor
jake sullivan
is that we do everything we do
must help advance working families and
the american middle class
and that certainly includes any trade
agreements and
that is part of their objective and how
they would approach it
but as you noted um at this point in
time we're working to
get the pandemic under control provide
economic relief to the american public
we of course can do multiple things at
the same time
but those are our primary priorities at
this point um
can i ask what happened to the churchill
bust and what should be read about its
removal from the oval office
oh such an important question it's the
plane of today um
i will follow up on that i don't have uh
it is it is something that may certainly
be
existing in the complex of course i'm
very familiar with the bust
um but uh we will circle back with you
if there's more to to update you on that
actually two follow-ups to what they
were just asking you um on
domestic unrest first of all does the
president have any comment on the
ongoing violence in oregon and
washington state that we've seen in
recent days
well certainly we had our team on the
ground our national security team even
before 1201 early in the morning on
inauguration day because we wanted to be
able to monitor
events happening across the country and
any unrest
that was resulting from
from the last couple of weeks i haven't
spoken with him specifically about those
events but it is something our national
security
team list sure when randall our homeland
security advisor is closely monitoring
of course
um and um but if we have an additional
update i'm happy to provide it to you
two more he's speaking with the leaders
of canada and mexico
any word on who else is next and has
there been any discussion about
when or under what conditions he the
vice president the secretary of state
would fly overseas
to meet with world leaders so uh despite
his desire my desire if that matters to
do a foreign trip
i think it will be a bit of time i don't
have an update for you on when that will
take place at this point
uh but i would expect he'll have of
course additional foreign leader calls
uh next week
as has has been the case with our
national security team you can
anticipate that those will start with
our allies and partners
including many of the europeans um but i
don't have a specific day by day
calendar for you at this point
his first weekend in the white house
does he still plan to go to mass
every weekend and has he picked a parish
here in the washington area or a place
where he plans to go
well his faith is certainly quite
important to him as you know from
covering him and
i would expect that he attends church
continues to attend
uh church very regularly um he has not
selected a church yet
um but um if if and when that happens
we'll certainly keep you updated
uh let's see i haven't taken the go
ahead all the way in the back so
japan is planning to host the tokyo
summer olympic game in six months
but they have not made a decision final
decision if it will go on at front or
recanted
because they're pandemic so does the
fighters expect
to be a game on as planned or
is a present violent confident to be a
safe origin game in tokyo
and that he feels safe to send
achievements remember the token this
summer
uh well as a big olympics fan i'm
certainly looking forward to
it um but i have not talked to the
president or
our national security team about um uh
plans for this summer or the games um
so we'll have to take that question too
and circle back with you
but did you have another one maybe i can
get another one yeah and how about the
uh
basic violence in the pacific policy
let's talk about japan and north korea
i understand the uh mr sullivan just
talked with his japanese
counterpart the party's u.s sports here
in japan
u.s policy and japan as it relates to
north korea
cool okay um well um our
the president's view is of course that
is without question that north korea's
nuclear ballistic missile
and other proliferation related
activities constitute syria's threat to
the international peace and security
uh of of the world and undermine the
global non-proliferation
regime and we obviously have still have
a vital interest
in deterring north korea as does japan
of course
um we will adopt a new strategy to keep
the american people and our allies safe
that approach will begin with a thorough
policy review of the state of play in
north korea
in close consultation with south korea
japan and other allies on
ongoing pressure options and the
potential for any future
diplomacy so i will say we will as we
have historically the united states will
work closely
with partners in the region uh to
determine a path forward and work
together on deterrence
epp is the present title concerning to
lead during the
tpp transit partnership uh well again i
think um
you know um president biden knows
tpp wasn't perfect and believes we need
to make it
stronger and better um but uh at this
point
uh you know our focus and his focus as
it relates to
the economy is on doing everything we
can
to advance working families in the
american middle class and so that will
be his focus in the coming months
uh go ahead justin um just a quick one
on
on inauguration day china sanctioned a
number of outgoing trump administration
officials
i know the nfc has put a statement out
kind of denouncing that saying that it
was a
political act but there's been a call
from some republicans on capitol hill
to either retaliate with sanctions
against chinese officials or to expel
the ambassador here in washington i'm
wondering if you're contemplating either
of those
actions um for those who didn't have the
statement well i'll just because it was
a
there's been a lot going on this week i
think we can all agree um
the biden harris administration has
noted china's sanctioning of more than
two dozen former trump administration
officials imposing these sanctions on
inauguration day
as they did as seemingly an attempt to
play partisan divides
americans of both parties should
criticize this unproductive and cynical
move and president biden looks forward
to working with leaders in both parties
to position america to outcompete china
i don't have any additional update
though
on other considerations go ahead thank
you ma'am um
this morning the white house put out a
statement on the anniversary of roe v
wade
as a candidate herself the vice
president proposed an abortion
rights law akin to the voting rights act
is that something that she still
supports is that something that the
president
is exploring uh i don't have any update
from the vice president's policy
obviously her policies or the policies
of the biden harris administration
and the statement today speaks to those
policies
oh we have ventured to get you a week
ahead and i promise that we will do it
in the future uh but we don't have any
uh really detailed specifics to share
with you at this point in time
other than the president will not be
leaving the dmv
i can assure you next week and he will
continue to sign additional
executive actions and engage with
members of congress
we will have a more detailed schedule
but we're still ironing out all
specifics
thank you everyone let's do this again
on monday
you